josée legault michel david hélène budget
du bon soir bon ça passe mon tour de
table sur monsieur bouchard je vais vous
faire un temps le premier ministre en a
parlé à sa conférence de presse
aujourd'hui quelque chose tu es capable
de bridge aux 5 tout en nous en
apprenant beaucoup pensent qu'une grande
perte de pourri québec je veux offrir
toutes mes condoléances à sa famille et
à ses proches
québec par quelqu'un qui analyse et
notre société sous toutes ses coutures
au cours des dernières années qui était
un excellent auteur
monsieur legault qui lui en troll son
dernier café avec marie il en a parlé
plus tard josé vous avez écrit un texte
également très beau sur monsieur
bouchard donc c'est une c'est une perte
sur une triste nouvelle aujourd'hui je
pense que cet achat carrément il faut
dire que c'était une nouvelle très très
inattendu et on ça comme un 8-1
je sais pas vraiment comment l'exprimer
autrement que depuis tellement d'années
que la voix de serge bouchard nous
accompagnent que si j'écris nous
accompagne moi aussi son avant-dernier
riverains café avec marie c'est vraiment
mon livre de chevet c'est celui qui me
calme pendant la pandémie le soir avant
d'un coup chili où deux textes sur de
courts textes y en a à peu près 60 10 je
pense beaucoup elle ou à sa fille la
fille qu'il a eue avec marie qu'ils ont
adoptés ensemble en chine et
à ces deux femmes qu'il a perdu au
cancer sa première épouse ginette ya
plus de 25 ans et mari qui est décédé
l'an dernier aussi
elle va partir très très figurants il a
été très éprouvée dans la vie mais il
l'a beaucoup aimé la vie et je pense que
c'est ce qui ressortait le plus de tout
son travail c est cuit ses émissions il
aimait la vie il aimait aimait il aimait
être mais il aimait le québec et même
les nations autochtones il aimait des
camionneurs il mais l'amérique et c'est
vraiment très grave
oui d'ailleurs vous avez raison il a
publié après un café avec marie sa thèse
sur les camionneurs sur l'amérique parce
qu'il aime l amérique du nord aussi dix
mois mais les gens de ma génération et
une triplette sur l'europe sur la france
dit moi j'aime notre côté du nord
américains à la fin de l'entrevue une
part de johnny cash etc
c'est très révélateur et il a mais
l'histoire de l'amérique
l'histoire de saint francophones qui ont
fait l'amérique
il nous fait découvrir cet homme là des
gens méconnu disparu ou les oublier sa
fameuse série 1 michel davy je vous
laisse la parole oui monsieur bouchard
était est un vieux sage même si à 73 ans
l'épithète est peut-être mal placé mais
c'était c'était ce genre
d'universitaires et sont pas si nombreux
qu'ils sont capables de faire partager
leurs réflexions avec tout le monde de
façon simple et avec humour et c'est un
moteur important de notre mémoire
collective et il monsieur monsieur
bouchard avait contrairement à beaucoup
de nos contemporains
un immense respect pour les hommes et
les femmes qui ont vécu au temps jadis
et
il avait compris lui que la vie est
beaucoup plus fait de petites choses que
de grands exploits
le café avec marie par exemple de titre
est tout à fait significatif je pense à
un autre titre acquis et qu'il avait
donné à un autre recueil de textes
c'était c'est la voiture noire
l'allume-cigare est dans la crèche le
noir monsieur bouchard lui avait compris
ça et il avait compris que le progrès
matériel n'est pas synonyme de progrès
de l'humanité à ids est souvent nos
ancêtres et à bien plus intelligents que
nous on sait pas s'il était plus
intelligent mais il était probablement
plus capable de composer d'accepter
isoler les contingences de la vie
quotidienne et c'est le désespérait de
voir qu'on connaissait pas assez notre
histoire
les noms de rues les l'idée pour les
gens c'est cdc des stations de métro ils
ne connaissent pas derrière les
personnages alors à lire heureusement
hélène il reste les livres il reste les
rings on peut lire pour se rattraper
pour ce que pour s'émouvoir parce qu'il
ya des passages très émouvant danser
dans ses écrits ce que je ferai car je
confesse de laval avoir beaucoup plus
connu à la radio que par ses écrits
écoutez je dirai simplement pour
rajouter à ce que tout ce que mes
collègues m'ont dit que c'était
évidemment une voix magnifique même voix
magnétique qui avait le pouvoir de nous
transporter c'était en fait c'était une
voix qui nous faisait voir et ça c'est
assez rare à la radio c'est c'est
vraiment un énorme micro qui s'est
éteint cette nuit
oui un homme libre et josé vous avez
raison pense à sa fille lou on pense à
sa fille lou et à son fils également le
fisc dans les laurentides et à tous ses
proches et toutes nos sympathies nos
condoléances alors voilà parle aussi
bien que celles ajouté j'en suis allé
avec ce qu'elle aime bien dire c'est que
vous allez voir il aime que lorsque vous
allez le lire
vous allez l'entendre on mais c'est
comme si nous aussi comme s'ils
n'avaient pas alors oui j'avais le
mélange moi je vous connais prennent un
petit jeu c'est ok parlant de liberté
pendant de liberté parce que je veux
dire c'est un homme libre
monsieur legault qui dit que la
vaccination et continue les allégories
sur la liberté la vaccination les côtes
vacciner ça rime avec liberté ça rime
avec solidarité ça rime surtout avec
bell était donc s'il vous plaît allez
vous faire vacciner tous les jeunes et
monsieur legault qui dit pour lanaudière
pour la montérégie pour les laurentides
également dont des régions importantes
la lumière s'en vient la zone orange
s'en vient
question presque d'heure disait-il alors
là on voit l'espoir et ont mis sur la
vaccination des jeunes et l'inde buzzati
oui ma faute je regardais les
statistiques aujourd'hui est notre cible
évidemment c'est le taux de 75% de
vaccination et si on regarde pour la
plupart des groupes âgées de plus de 40
de 55 ans pardon on a atteint ce seuil
où on est sur le point de l'atteindre
avec les rendez-vous qui sont au prix
évidemment je serai un peu plus
sympathique pour les plus jeunes qui
peuvent à peine commencé à prendre des
rendez vous mais pour les 40 à 45 ans on
constate que même avec les rendez-vous
qui sont en attente là on atteint poste
75% et je pense que il y as peut-être
les gérer ce à l'horizon le fait qu' on
s'assoit un peu sur nos lauriers il
soufflera ouais voilà on sent que les
choses vont mieux je vais messages sont
possibles au décroche
donnez-moi j'expliquais graphique qui
hélas pas ça c'est nouveau
ces nouveaux d'aujourd'hui les nouveaux
cieux du bk twitté on le verra après le
truc mais restons sur le graphique ça
c'est les pourcentages rsa à monter
magiquement pendant les nuits c'est que
les premières doses cinquante deux pour
cent de la population
quand on prend en compte les rangs des
vous on monte à 66% vous allez me dire
il me semble qu'on t'a à 40 au québec
oui mais ça c'est quand on compte en
fonction de la population adulte et ça
sera ça le seuil l'andropause 75% de la
population
en comptant les gens de 12 ans et moins
alors si tous les gens qui ont pris des
rendez-vous au cours des prochaines
semaines niveau on va monter assez vite
à 66 pour ça l'asim je vous le rappelle
c'est 75% donc il a quand même ça avance
il me faudra voir dans quelle mesure les
jeunes vont à l'ip lait y aura ensuite
les élèves du secondaire qui se font
vacciner mais chelle un vide quand même
jusqu'ici l'autobus avant cela ils
avancent plus vite qu'on pensait bon
pour les les gens d'âge scolaire je
pense pas qu'il ya un gros problème
c'est pas cela qui vont être les la
clientèle la plus difficile à vacciner
ce sont les 18-30 le qui naturellement
sont plutôt insouciant disent on ne voit
pas trop trop de problèmes mais on le
voit depuis une semaine du jour de la
stratégie de communication du
gouvernement changer on va pas il me
voir ces jeunes en leur disant que le
système hospitalier saturés puisque il
faut délester puis et 4 monsieur legault
dit liberté bel été ça ça ils peuvent
comprendre ça il faut y aurait pu
ajouter partez
concert rock pour ouvrir disons la porte
à toutes ces belles choses et la
vaccination est un passage obligé et ça
je pense qu'il ya de bonnes chances
qu'ils le comprennent - jose oui mais
surtout que le 75 pour ça comme niveau
de dignité collective c'est quand même
un chiffre qui est conservateur avait
des experts qui monte jusqu'à 85 et 90
et il faut rappeler que c'est on parle
de la première dose comme justin trudeau
a dit aujourd'hui on se souhaite un été
à une dose pour avoir un automne à deux
doses bon et là aussi c'est la petite
inquiétude c'est à dire oui des tranches
d'âge qu'on ne sait pas si vraiment ça
va aller comme le dit michel si ça
valait aussi rondement
je quitte à me répéter je redis que les
travailleurs de la santé aussi qui
refuse toujours d'être vaccinés qui sont
en contact direct avec des personnes
vulnérables ça je sais pas ce que le
gouvernement attend pour rendre
obligatoire et il y a le fait que
beaucoup de personnes dont nous au babc
le mans nous avons nous rendez vous pour
la deuxième dose pendant l'été c'est ce
qu'on nous a données alors là est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui vont être en
vacances est ce que déjà qu'ils vont
décider de passer par dessus la deuxième
dose donc ce que ça veut dire c'est que
les efforts de communication ciblée pour
le gouvernement c'est loin d'être
terminée là il va faire que ce soit de
plus en plus chirurgicale selon doit
avec à vos feuilles qui sont bien
certains quartiers on va écouter on
voulait parler mais surtout dont on va
l'écouter rapidement il parle de 75% il
parle aussi du passeport vaccinale en
écoute on a besoin d'avoir plus que 75 %
à des citoyens vacciner avec une
première dos à et qu'on continue avec
les deuxièmes dos pour avoir à un été à
une dose pour ce faire il ya beaucoup de
gens qui regardent l'idée que avec une
preuve de vaccination on pourrait faire
plus de choses faut s'assurer qu'on
n'est pas en train d'être injuste
juste content des gens déjà
marginalisées ou déjà vulnérables ou des
foyers un peu plus de réticence
on a parlé la semaine dernière de cette
preuve actional élan buzzati on sent oui
parce que ça sera un incitatif énorme
pour dire je n'ai pas de preuves vous
rentrerez pas au restaurant en même
table sur 12 dit oui mais il ya des
clientèles qui seront pas vaccinés est
ce qu'on peut aussi simple que cela
non et je trouve ça quand même assez
étrange de savoir qu'il a beaucoup de
préoccupation face à la preuve vaccinale
lorsqu'il vient le temps de parler de
certaines communautés
je pense qu'ils pensaient à des
communautés racisées peut-être qu'ils
sont peut-être moins vacciner et donc on
pourrait les ostraciser mais que la
question de la liberté de la protection
des renseignements personnels me sens
pas là le préoccuper autant et en fait
je constate de la part des chefs
fédéraux en général une très grande
frilosité à se prononcer sur cette
question
le bloc québécois par exemple se réfugie
derrière ça sa parade habituelle à sa
relève des provinces donc ce n'est pas à
moi d'en parler
monsieur singh qui ne veut pas se
prononcer là dessus dit je veux voir ce
que disent les experts
on sent que les politiciens fédéraux se
disent c'est pas nous qui allons décider
soit de toute manière c'est explosé
michel et georges éthier j'exagère
peut-être plus mais totalement pour la
semaine dernière d'un michel pinget gens
d'aller à qui restera il ya des gens qui
pour des raisons médicales par exemple
ne peuvent pas recevoir des vaccins et
je pense qu'il y avait lieu d'avoir
je sais pas une preuve
médical du patient de l'avoir mais de
façon générale je pense que deux sur une
courte période là on s'entend faudrait
que ça soit assez court jusqu'à ce que
la pandémie soit sous contrôle je pense
que c'est à la fois une incitation fort
et
une façon de retrouver plus rapidement
une vie normale et de sorte que les gens
qu'ils l'auraient pas vont retrouver une
vie normale plus rapidement eux aussi
dans la mesure où les autres pour aller
au restaurant par exemple se seront fait
vacciner ouais josé j'ai tout à fait
d'accord aussi c'est un privilège
non je n'ai pas changé d'idée là dessus
je comprends par contre les
questionnements de monsieur trudeau
questionne aussi ailleurs dans le monde
mais en même temps et les pays qui ont
adopté cette approche là on à le parler
le danemark en israël etc sont pas plus
fou que nous et puis ça ça semble bien
fonctionner mais leur taux de
vaccination est plus avancé que l'on
donc comme le dit michel ce serait une
mesure temporaire il faudrait aussi
qu'elle s'applique une fois qu'on a une
bonne majorité de la population que une
première dose avec l'exception de
liberté tout ça mais on est en pandémie
c'est une situation exceptionnelle alors
sa demande
on continue à demander des mesures
exceptionnelles tant que ça va durer
très bien il reste quoi trois minutes à
peu près
rapidement aux à michel vous avez écrit
un texte matin sur le parti québécois on
a posé la question au chef du pq est
vous décourager des sondages qui le
placent à 12 % au québec
voici ce qu'il a répondu ce matin
et c'est difficile de évaluer la valeur
de ces sondages lorsque
vraisemblablement le sujet de discussion
de préoccupation pour les gens c'est de
se sortir de la pandémie c'est sûr que
c'est pas le chiffre que je voudrais en
date d'aujourd'hui mais ça me faisait
également penser qu'un à la course à la
chefferie
j'avais tout lâché j'avais quitté mon
emploi
puis un sondage léger qui m'avait placé
à 5%
il la question c'est ce que je lâche
puis j'ai décidé de poursuivre mes
convictions de pas lâcher le morceau
parce que je croyais en ce que je
faisais puis finalement j'ai fini à 56
pour ça
alors tour de table rappelle josée
legault je pense que monsieur c'est
probablement dont l'aïd c'est bien
plamondon pendant qu'on font vraiment de
choses d'une course à la chefferie et
puis le déclin continu du parti
québécois depuis le dernier référendum
c'est quand même une réalité objective
qui était amorcée le bien bien d'avoir
la pandémie la pandémie ne peut être qu
empirer à peine la situation mais vous
savez moi j'ai déjà dit j'ai déjà écrit
un texte dont le site était maman
c'était quoi le pq bon disons qu'il ya
un danger il ya vraiment un ancien chef
oui la pandémie à sa malle à tous les
partis est pour rien qu au québec à tous
les partis d'opposition ayant goûté par
à camper la pandémie mais quand on voit
la situation du pq contrairement par
exemple aux libéraux qui peuvent encore
se raccrocher à leur base non
francophones qui qui qui plie toujours
aussi solide
à québec solidaire chi chi le premier
parti chez les jeunes le pq est il le
dernier partout dans toutes les
catégories bas toutes les régions à peu
près sauf les francophones je pense les
libéraux encore plus de problèmes mais
il n'y a rien là sur quoi il peut
s'accrocher pour rebâtir après la
pandémie bon hélène piqûre ou je vous
donne le choix peut parler de
l'opposition fédérale
est-ce que c'est pas pas facile dans
l'opposition non c'est jamais facile
d'être l'opposition et à ottawa comme à
québec il ya de ça effectivement pour le
pq mais clairement le pq et les
péquistes
ils ont migré à la cac c'est là qu'il
est le nouveau pq et et je ne sais pas
comme l'écrivait je pense michel
asynchrone et qu'est ce qu'il y aura un
après françois legault à la carte qu'est
ce que ce parti
l'os survivre à son chef on verra mais
pour l'instant tant que monsieur legault
elop de l'abandon ramasse tous votre
longue tresse merci beaucoup à vous
trois très gentil merci au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit